Herman Edwards here on the Rich Eisen
show how are you coach I am well part
participating practice a little later on
this afternoon and getting ready to play
a game that's believe it or not college
football season upon us there's a lot of
exciting bands on the country obviously
we're excited here as well and what
about you being back with a whistle and
a headset and men to coach rich I'm back
in my elevator I really miss the
camaraderie and developing young men and
this is what I do is what I've always
done I've always been a football coach
especially when I retired from playing
all those you know being back is where I
belong I feel very very comfortable in
this environment got a fairly pretty
good football team to work with the
annex Americas but but I think we have
some experienced professional players
there and we've acquired some as well
now they have 15 new players that
weren't here in this frame and actually
will help us try to win football games
this year so it's been it's been a good
return for me and all all the sense of
being back on the grass and being around
a coaching staff and young football
players now you know I've been around a
bunch of coaches who have gone into TV
work and and media work I sit next to
one in Mariucci and every single time we
go to a game and we're covering a game
and which gets on the sidelines he puts
his hands on his hips he starts talking
to the refs he starts talking to the
players and the coaches and we all have
some fun just saying it's always in them
it's always in a coach why is that
why can't coaches get coaching out of
their blood DNA what you've done your
whole life you know I've been rich
getting high school athlete and
premiered
going into college level a good
apprentice college athlete new premier
now I have an opportunity to play in a
national football league and coaching a
football league for 30 years so my life
has always been around football in that
aspect of it and I was fortunate dusty
could work on television for a while but
still still coaching football to be
quite honest and maybe learning
about football when you step back from
it and you marry bitching Coach mooch I
mean look good friends we go way back we
coach that underarm all-american that's
right really we had a blast coaching
those years you know so it's in your DNA
and it's innocent waste either we play
football you know I am I am an
ambassador for the game of football I
mean football has been my whole life
anything I can give back to it I'm
embedded to this game and I think when
you've done it and played it and coach
it as long as I have you had a lot of
information give back to football and
try to make the game better Herman
Edwards Arizona State head coach here on
the Richardson show what about though
reaching 17 18 19 year old kids yeah not
really I think they all want the same
thing that all players want how can you
make them better I think today's
athletes a little bit different you
gotta tell them why first you gotta tell
them why well why do you know that we
grew up it was Howard in the wine I tell
my you know they still learn but but but
they're learning mechanisms
a little bit different you know they're
they're they're so including two to two
things that happen really fast that's
that new generation of kids but they
still want to learn I think housing
codes in the classrooms a bit different
than how you coach to 20 years ago but
still the fundamentals ability to coach
on the grass in the classroom state is
saying how can you develop a players you
can't give in talent God gives them
talent how can you develop his skills to
make him successful looks player ones
that well a couple years ago Dabo
Swinney took Clemson to Syracuse and
pointed out the Jim Brown banner and a
lot of kids didn't even know the Jim
Brown was have you had a moment like
that with these kids actually go back to
the history of this place and talked
about the players that have been here
before and I think I did that
professionally or football as well they
don't know the shoulders of standing on
you know there was always so helpful for
you good about that and I think if let
him learn a little bit of the history of
the game they're playing
and when they leave it I've always gone
players and coaches as well we got to
make it better put a guy who follow us
that's critical because this is a great
great game well and if you ever want to
teach the kids uh never give up
mentality never give up on a play never
give up on a game never give up on a
moment all they got it all you got to do
is just put on the film of somebody in
the Meadowlands back in the 70s right
after every you know Friday practice and
professional football it was it was
Saturday and then walk through em you
know you line up to victory formation
and because you wanted to see that right
and I can remember in total while I said
you know I said why don't people do this
to the rookies right because they just
do it I say well google it why this
happens the night meeting they go you
told your kids to google it is it people
getting this formation all the time I
said yeah well how does this thing come
about how does this become about right
they're kind of looking at me with big
eyes people 1978 you know Meadowlands
you know whatever that is amazing that
is just amazing so you're talking about
learning what have you learned so far as
you're getting ready for your first game
UTSA and then Michigan State in an a
home game for you 20 timeout rich 20
came out to the college football game
that's nuts
play last forever you know I mean it
just keeps going
yeah and spread offense obviously I mean
that's that's that's college football
now but it's all good a bunch you know
you're talking about 7580 plays in a
football game but some things don't
change I mean still have to be
disciplined in what you do I still think
in football two things come to mind
especially
authentically to score points you got to
be able to throw it to win games gotta
run defensively I think if your sound
tackling and college football I think
I'd be really really good in the red
zone because people move the ball
they just do because the way they spread
you out you know there's a lot of green
short path that get guys in space got a
tackle well so I think all those things
become a big factor football and here's
that really is this thing for me because
you guys haven't been on this field but
in college football the dimensions of
the field again you know in the fact of
the hashes you know they're 12 yards so
all of a sudden on one hash you're the
left hash there's a lot of feel the
other side you're a football Bob always
in the middle in college football
there's a feel time you know and there's
fog aside this different mm-hmm a couple
more minutes left with Herman Edwards
here Arizona State head coach so you're
you're there in Arizona State you got
someone in Arizona Chip Kelly now and
UCLA I mean you or a cow guy going way
back in the day so you're despite having
worked at ESPN as I did and heard all
that talk of East Coast bias you know
you are well versed know okay on West
west of the Rockies so my question for
you is where do you think the pac-12
ranks coach well I think this I think
look at last year Susan to drop along
with 30-plus guys almost one shot guys
got drafted is gonna average power but I
but I think this and then you know this
due to the fact that a lot of the games
were at night you don't see the talent
here this is a talented conference of
players you look to quarterback
suggested in the first trial out of this
conference there's a lot of players that
come out of this conference it's West
Coast bank so I won't be believable I
grew up on the west coast suspension I
went to Cal when it was back eight all
right how about that playing against 26
killer and guys like that you know Bobby
Moore Ahmad Rashad you know all those
this problem a conference you know on
the chuck Muncie I was a teammate of
mine Steve brickowski you know Wesley
Walker Vince Ferragamo on a play with
those guys a cow so this is rich
conference of players and then how do
you just one last one for your home
respond to somebody whose hears this and
understands what you've been and done
that it's now the 21st century and
Herman Edwards might not be equipped to
do that how do you respond to that well
I think we live our lives yet the
perception of others never been my
reality you know I won't allow it to be
you know I mean when you take on
something like this it's what I do to be
quite honest I've always been a coach at
heart and there's nothing change for me
it's you you walk on the field and you
get to whistle when you go and you just
coach you know the good thing about it I
got a great staff and I can relate to
the players there's no problem there and
asking is required to play for me that's
a good part and I coach the players I
don't try to coach anybody outside of
the players hmm and where have you told
the kids what they play to to the game
for that's right you had them at hello
in a way hey coach I'm really excited to
watch Arizona State football this week
this uh this fall and to see what's
going down with you I'm you've always
been one of my favorites so I wanted to
check in with you I know that right back
at you that's Harmon Edwards at Herm
Edwards on Twitter Arizona State head
coach here in the Rich Eisen show so
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience